the internet was alive with the sound of
criticism over the latest trailer for
the female lead Ghostbusters reboot
there may be more moaning on the way as
there have also been developments on a
female-led reboot of ocean's 11 I'm
Simon and this is your entertainment
news update oscar-winning Hunger Games
actress Jennifer Lawrence is a
frontrunner to play the right-hand woman
to Sandra Bullock's character in the
upcoming female in Ocean's eleven reboot
which claims Lawrence is at the top of
the producers shortlist the ocean's 11
reboot is being directed by Gary Ross
who also directed 2012's Hunger Games it
would be the first time that Lawrence
and Ross have reunited for a movie since
sources told the tracking board that the
female orientated follow-up focuses on
Bullock's character an ex-con and the
sister of Danny ocean in the original
trilogy George Clooney played that part
with a team of thieves she sets out to
steal the necklace from the Met Ball and
frame a crooked gallery owner Lawrence
is being considered for the role of
Bullock's right-hand woman in October
last year Warner Brothers confirm the
all-female Ocean's eleven movie Clooney
is said to be producing alongside Steven
Soderbergh who directed the earlier
trilogy which itself was a remake of the
1960 movie starring Frank Sinatra and
Dean Martin the picture has been in
development for some time and it was
allegedly a big reason for the fast
tracking of the competing female-led
reboot of ghostbusters at sony which is
now set for july 2016 release the 2001
ocean's 11 and 450 million dollars
worldwide and while the two sequels were
not quite as successful they all prove
to be considerable box-office hits what
do you think of this recent spell of
gender swapping reboots could you
imagine Jemma bond or a lab based sex in
the city let me know what you think in
the comments or come find me on Twitter
i'm at the Jagan or thanks for watching
and for your entertainment news keep it
gamespot